I give myself just six months to prove
that I can create a sustainable business
I understand that this is a prison but
I'm finding incredibly difficult to get
the prisoners out of their cells and
working because of the prison
authorities stringent rules and
regulations I think part of their
problem there's so short-staffed and so
for them to keep the peace and put the
more time you spend in your cell makes
their life easier
so they don't want you out remembers
these guys are here for reasons the
place can it can erupt it can go and
sometimes it's over the slightest thing
and we've got to keep that under control
what users happy to cut a month so it
amounts to use it that more might mean
finger look at myself
then what imprisoned change people
trying people change it so prison that
work prison mark mopping I don't come on
okay little ass in the others don't [ __ ]
oh thanks a dugong no needs to work no
one needs to come and commit the system
screwed here that's the issues the
governor ed Tullett wants me to get the
prisoners grafting but he admits the
prison system doesn't make it easy
we're things that work very number of
reasons being in a prison is not all
things being working on the outside but
it will to get through you've got a gate
to get through you've got security
systems we've routines hospitals
themselves reasons as are in jail are
probably the same reasons haven't got
jobs in the first place
come in guys let's go I'm under no
illusions this lot are no angels before
they're ready to produce lunches to sell
outside prison my system GN I need to
finish their kitchen training a few
weeks ago they couldn't even scramble an
egg today we're cooking chicken Kiev's
from scratch but not everyone in Brixton
prison appears to be taking our project
as seriously as I'd like repeat offender
test for Jones is unhappy with his
treatment by the officers on the wing
had a shower for a couple of days now I
don't want to come into the kitchen and
grimy person who's not that you so
deserve the senior officer of the wing
he's safer every funnel gray so we don't
actually work him so I was there with us
at all
this is crazy today's work I need to
know that just that's ridiculous
anyone working on this prisoner gets a
special time stop you can take a shower
after working but they're saying it's
not work you're having fun yeah no all
right I thought the office would be in
support of them but on the opposite way
if Tesla has been singled out for the
wrong sort of special treatment I need
to talk to the officers concerned I want
them to see this is not a jolly and
feedback your side they are absolutely
head down and they are grafting in there
a lot I don't know half the summer don't
believe it does it tell me push the
broom up and down the ladder they're
working very hard you know yeah
no but they said that they weren't
getting showered last week too nice from
the trot and this is a fair go they do
I'm struggling because there's issues
when they come back on the wing that
they're complaining about you guys they
treat us like [ __ ] they think we're on
special privileges not work the officers
don't think we work in so they take us
down the realms of winding us up no I
can tell you that more important things
to do them yeah I can say that now no
one goes out their way to wind them up
are they starting to piss you off a
couple of them think they're superstars
mr. Jones specifically came you know the
other day shouting the odds he wants a
shower calling me all those in the Sun
[ __ ] hole and God knows what yeah if
someone comes to me and I tell them
three times they can't have a shower a
shout and scream and call me names then
there's very little I can do about that
frustrating yeah appreciate your time
I'll keep roses I know these officers
are doing their best under enormous
pressure but they have a very different
take on events to test for I see him
working more than they see him working
they see him Stephen I see him working
so you know we've got a meet in the
middle and I'm not gonna take everything
a screw says 100 percent go in there and
lay into them know that because I'm back
to square one
the prisoners back to square one the
systems back to square one and in ten
years time we're still in this [ __ ]
situation so it's a [ __ ] nightmare I
mean it really is right now on the
fourth floor here yeah I feel like the
governor's [ __ ] no don't do something
we can't do and I'm not Eddie toilets
[ __ ]